but sometimes the home team is not the
home team and that's the case tonight
daniel ponce de leon and the cardinals
have taken the field
and that's how we'll start game two the
cardinals are the home team
and ponce will face reynolds hayes and
moran
for pittsburgh in the first inning and
the cardinals are so happy that this
is their next to last double header so
here is brian reynolds the cardinals on
the road we've seen this a time or two
serving as the home team
and a fly ball lifted out to shallow
center and that'll drop in
for a base hit in front of dylan carlson
so two outs and the runner at first and
josh bell
batting 244-7 home runs runner at first
base for the pirates the pitch
a swing and a miss he struck him out
that was 95 mile an hour heat away
ponce de leon gave up a hit but the
pirates couldn't score we played a half
inning and the cardinals are coming to
bat in pittsburgh
wong started the game game one with a
home run off the foul pole and right off
trevor williams
keep ryan hayes picks it 360 spin that's
a pretty thing to see
that's a good play there to his left
he's that short stop right there by the
way
yeah yeah he had the hitting room over
there on the left side and and hayes
took it away
in a hurry that brings up paul
goldschmidt
two strike pitch again from cool right
there strike three call frozen with a
fastball right over the outer edge
chad cool with a pair of strikeouts in
the first
second on its way from pnc park no score
and three strikeouts in a row for daniel
ponce de leon
bell polanco and gonzalez and now with
two outs in the second
up comes second baseman kevin newman now
the pitch
and that is a high fly ball short right
field and on comes tommy edmond to make
a running catch tough play
well there's no chance for wong or
carpenter to make the play
tommy edmond turned it in and a three at
three down second inning we go to the
bottom of the second
short lead at first that's jacob
stallings
and it's a swing and a miss strikeout
number four for daniel
you got to think that daniel relishes
this you know he's kind of on the
outside looking in for the starting
rotation and now here he is twice in one
week
here's the first pitch and a swing and a
fly ball out to right
edmond in a few steps he makes a catch
and the inning is through
walking a man left through two and a
half in pittsburgh
pirates and cardinals no score
left-handed batter now at 186.
he's got three home runs and 21 rbis
right-hander chad
cool ready is two two pits now and a
swing and a messy struck him out
does anybody put a ball and play against
chad yet oh yeah there's
uh three different occasions two of them
were in fair territory even
he is mowing up down front back to the
mound thrown on the first bell with a
nice stretch gets wong and the inning is
over and tonight chad cool
couldn't be anything but that he has
been in command
and he sends down the cardinals in the
third so we'll go to the fourth inning
nothing nothing seems to be fine after
again being angry with himself here
after this moment he'll stop and oh
something happened there something grab
him shift on the right side 3-2 pitch
josh bell swaying and a miss he struck
him out
that's six tonight for daniel chased the
ball up in the zone and gets his six
strikeout
swinging miss stuff tonight for daniel
ponce de leon
looking for his seventh strikeout here's
the one two to him and a swing in a line
drive
underneath the backhanded try of miller
the third baseman goes into left
and gregory polanco aborted first with
two outs
and the cardinals have something going
here in the bottom of the fourth
shortstop paul to
young 3-2 pitch and the young lifts a
fly ball
out to shallow left that drops in tommy
edmond will score
and the cardinals have the lead and base
running again by goldschmidt to take
third and the cardinals have a
one-nothing lead
paul deyoung comes through with his 23rd
rbi of the year and the cardinals are on
top
that was a tough battle there and him a
slider away but not in the dirt
not in the dirt is right and he earned
that 3-2 pitch by not swinging at the
2-2 pitch and he didn't hit it hard
martin just recalled today
he struck him out strikeout number eight
for daniel ponce de leon
that was daniel punch-out de leon brian
reynolds a base head and a strikeout
fly ball to right and clear the deck
cannonball coming brian reynolds
into the river someone might have to go
explore that
the home run off ponce de leon gives the
bucks
a 2-1 lead number five for reynolds
the bases are loaded and cool he's
shaking his head
this thing turned two walks in the
inning it's 2-1 here the first pitch to
de-young
andy young sends a high-fly ball into
right polanco
over he'll make the catch
everybody tagging up tommy edmond he'll
score
they miss the cut and everybody moving
up a base
runners at second and third with one out
2-2 our score here in the bottom of the
sixth the o2 pitch
there's a ground ball to the third
baseman coming home the throw is high
and goldsmith scores the go ahead run
the ball went to the backstop
and on to third base goes miller there's
carpenter with runners at
first and third carpenter pulls it right
side
they're gonna try to go for two and they
throw it away another run will score
that's bader pirates have unraveled here
in the sixth with
the walks the catchers interference and
two errors
two runners on and carlson hits it a ton
out to deep right
it is gone three-run
homer dylan carlson and the cardinals
have busted it open
on a three-run blast from the rookie
the 2-1 is popped up
on the infield and it is caught tommy
edmond has it and the cardinals have a
sweep of the doubleheader they come back
late in game two and they win it seven
to two